startling one for nine
in this series thus far with a strikeout
martay with a drive out to center marco
is back
and it clears the wall in dead center
field a home run for starling marte
well that's the way you play off of
yesterday's ball game you come back out
in the first inning and you get right
back after it my goodness
arena up there now
[Applause]
high fly ball lifted into right center
field that's got some carry
gonna get out of here home run
rosarina his second of the year
pretty good opposite field power there
a lot of carry third major league start
for trevor rogers coming off his first
big league win that's not uh that's not
a bad one to get by the way
chases that one and wallock will apply
the tag
and he called strike three so a couple
decays in the first
for rogers kevin smith with two outs
all right another strikeout for rogers
two to one after two
dickerson that is a fair ball and that's
going to go down the line
hustling towards second base it gets
caught up in the corner and dickerson's
thinking about three he's
chugging and he will make it a leadoff
triple to start the third
look at this alignment yeah low is about
halfway in between first and second
doesn't matter
doesn't matter at all aguilar with a
base hit
and that'll score dickerson
take that take that shift there you go
you're gonna do it
i'll go the other way jesus was staring
it down just before the pitch
i mean are you kidding me look for
something away and just put the barrel
on it how many times have we seen him do
this
strikeout looking of low fourth
strikeout for rogers
two and two and a swing and a miss
so rogers able to strand a runner
a swing and a miss there for rogers so
strikeout number six
and a second time wing and that's now
seven strikeouts a new career high for
trevor rogers on another strikeout for
rogers he strikes out the side it's four
in a row
bottom of the fifth with hunter renfrow
leading off
fly ball down the right side that ball
is going to stay fair
and will get out of here how about that
a 1-2 pitch he got beneath it
and just down that line and inside the
foul ball for his sixth home run of the
year
[Applause]
and a call old strike three right at the
bottom of the zone
that is nine for rogers
for his last 13 double-digit strikeouts
for trevor rogers
on to the bottom of the sixth inning
randy
rosarina here with a home run and a fly
ball to right
in this game there's a shot down the
left field line
is that going to get the low wall that
and more
gone for a runs arena his second home
run
and this game is tied at three how about
that
randy rosarina with his second home run
of the day
and the rays are back even
yeah this young man is on fire
no strikes and this into
center jazz chisholm makes the play
what a grab by jazz just kind of
floating out into center field
and then reaching out and hanging on a
great defensive play
oh my goodness
wow what a play by jazz
feet off the ground football season
isn't for a week
and a half swing well look at that not
to be outdone
brian anderson takes away a hit and
marlins are flashing the leather here in
the eighth inning yeah they certainly
are a check swing line drive
off the bat of lao full extension to the
backhand my goodness ba
so there will be extra innings on a
sunday afternoon
it's up to joyce there's a 2-2 and a
ground ball and it's gonna get through
the raise at the shift on
and it's going to score a run brinson in
and it's 4-3 marlins with
wendell at second base
g-man choi ground ball that's a fair
ball up the right side
extra bases here comes wendell he'll tie
the game
and joy becomes the runner at second
down
g-man choi comes through here at the
bottom of the 10th
to make it a 4-4 ball game he's trying
to make something happen
he got bookends right there first and
third with
a ton of speed one out 3-2 to loud
and a fly ball back into center field
that's going to be
caught by marte no chance
the tag at third phillips scores and the
rays win it
in 10.